Chelsea Clinton says she didn't get  pregnant to make her mother's seem more  human but come on  does she seriously expect us to believe  she was having sexual intercourse while  not thinking about her mother would  create human life just to distract  voters from Benghazi I was born to but  not yesterday how much do we really know  about fetal fetal Clinton never started  a business met a payroll or created a  single job it just lies there jobless  and naked an American mother in the  kidney and when fetal Clinton is born  naturally it's going to be someone  else's job to clean up the mess but it  won't be the first Clinton to get DNA  all over an intern can America really  afford to more trimesters of fetal  Clinton called voodoo Clinton and tell  it the American people deserve to  finally get an answer to the question  where's the birth certificate  [Applause]